[Music]
in tonight's whatever happened to
segment new developments in the case of
an elite military operator accused of
killing a Taliban bomb maker you saw his
declaration or confession right here on
special report national security
correspondent Jennifer Griffin has our
update tonight from the Pentagon the US
Army has charged with alleged murder a
once decorated Green Beret who received
a Silver Star for valor in Afghanistan
but later admitted to killing a detainee
during an interview with Fox News's Bret
Baier in October 2016
did you kill the Taliban bomb maker yes
major Matthew Goldstein was a US Special
Forces soldier attached to a Marine unit
that faced heavy fighting in the battle
for Marja in February 2010 he later
acknowledged during a polygraph when
applying for a job at the CIA that he
had killed an alleged Taliban member who
they suspected of planting a bomb that
killed two Marines sergeant Jeremy
McQueary and Lance Corporal Larry
Johnson you willingly offered up these
details right at the CIA right that's
correct and that's where it all started
pretty much according to a senior
defense official Goldstein told the CIA
he killed the Afghan off base placed his
body into a pit and burned it but
reached by telephone Goldstein told Fox
News quote I made a lawful engagement of
a known enemy combatant on the
battlefield he says the rules of
engagement were so strict at the time
that they were only allowed to detain
and process Afghans for drug crimes
Goldstein says following the suspected
Afghan bomb makers release he tracked
him down and killed him Goldstein said
he believed that letting go of the
insurgent meant the man could later
target Afghans who were helping US
troops you can construe it as a law
enforcement mindset there's limits on
how long you can hold guys so we would
pull these guys out we'd say clearly
these are enemy combatants these are
Taliban these are bad dudes we'd pull
him out but we wouldn't have any place
to hold so eventually we'd let him back
and they would cost here to the
community again a senior US defense
official confirmed to Fox News the
Army's Criminal Investigation Command
reopened the investigation based on new
evidence that includes the Green Berets
public statements the Defense
Department's inspector general
investigated the Army's original
handling of the case which found not
enough evidence to prosecute Goldstein
after a six-day hearing California
congressman Duncan Hunter a former
Marine who served in Iraq has championed
Goldstein's case he wrote the following
letter to army chief general mark Milley
quote Goldstein is an American Hero a
true warrior in fact why the Army is
hell-bent on destroying a combat heros
career is truly astonishing I'm
confident that army CID has more
important things to do than investigate
Goldstein again and you both have the
ability to fix this stupidity what is it
like going from war hero - accused war
criminal
are you angry no it has been incredibly
painful very and very difficult over the
last year of these years everyone who
served with me stood by me and so kind
of its over and a lot of times have on
sources tell me that when Goldstein
admitted killing a man in cold blood on
television the army investigators had no
choice but to reopen the case
major Goldstein claims that strict rules
of engagement forced him to release the
alleged Taliban bomb maker who had been
fingered by an Afghan informant and that
he had no choice to act as he did but
those to whom I've spoken here at the
Pentagon say he did have a choice and
now major Matthew Goldstein has been
charged with premeditated murder and
could face the death penalty
Brett Jennifer Griffin at the Pentagon
Jennifer thank you